tu es prête John oui
[Musique]
tu viens lui dire adieu je viens la
saluer
tu crois que ta femme peut t'entendre
non
alors pourquoi tu es
je peux me tromper
tu vas mourir
peut-être pas
[Musique]
un nouveau jour se lève nouvelle idée
nouvelle règle nouvelle organisation
[Musique]
le marquis de Grammont
défilé en combat singulier
gagne ou père c'est à celui-ci
je ne siège pas la table ta famille le
fait
[Musique]
un homme doit être à son avantage pour
son mariage ou ses funérailles
je vais avoir besoin d'une arme
si vous gagnez
la table tiendra sa parole
vous retrouverez votre liberté
selon les anciennes lois un seul peut
survivre
toute absence au lever du jour
[Applaudissements]
impliquera une exécution
un dernier mot Winston amuse-toi bien à
la barre
[Musique]
je veux que tu trouves la paix une bonne
mort
n'arrive qu'après une bonne vie
nous avons renoncé à une bonne vie
depuis bien longtemps mon ami
[Musique]